[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: At
Hillsdale, we believe
that college isn't just
something you go to,
it's something you become a part
of for the rest of your life.
This is why every student
beginning their journey
at Hillsdale is asked
to commit themselves
to a set of principles known
as the Freshman Pledge.
This pledge reminds
us that college is not
a commodity, but a commitment.
And it defines this relationship
between college and student,
a partnership where
Hillsdale promises
not only to provide
a good education,
but to lead every student forth
towards a good and noble life.
Through this pledge,
we commit ourselves
to diligent study and
patient reflection,
to learning and living
with integrity and honor.
We embrace the highest ideals
of a liberal arts education,
the pursuit of truth,
the love of the good,
and the cultivation of beauty.
And we believe that the
pursuit of these ideals
will shape our minds and our
hearts for an ennobled society.
This is the high calling
of a Hillsdale education.
This is the Freshman Pledge.
[MUSIC PLAYING]